you know what let me ask a question so
I'll start this off with the perhaps the
most basic question we say that
conscious or some people say that
Consciousness is fundamental and then
there's various questions like well what
is consciousness so here's another
question what is fundamental so what's
fundamental if one doesn't assume
reductionism and if one does have to
assume reductionism for something to be
fundamental then does that mean that
conceptually reductionism is more
fundamental than the x that you're
saying is fundamental so anyway what is
fundamental
I'll be happy to start sure sure so I
think that there's two important and
different concepts going on here one is
um reductionism which has to do with an
assumption about space-time being
fundamental
and with reductionism the idea is that
as you go to smaller and smaller scales
in space-time
you get to more and more fundamental
objects and more and more fundamental
laws
so that's a particular idea and by the
way reductionism is assuming uh um that
space-time itself is fundamental I mean
because it's taking smaller scales of
space as being associated with more and
more fundamental objects and laws
but fundamental for me is a much broader
concept than than say space time
fundamental is a property of scientific
theories so every scientific theory
um has assumptions
no theory in science is free of any
assumptions and these assumptions are
the foundation of that scientific theory
and so what's fundamental is Vis it is
is with respect to a particular Theory
what what does that take as the
fundamental uh concepts for building
that theory so I I I think the notion of
fundamental is a theory
relative concept you should ask
um what's fundamental in this particular
scientific theory in Einstein's theory
of gravity space-time is fundamental in
uh you know Evolution Financial
selection we have the notion of physical
objects in space-time and things like
genes and competition and replication
those are those are fundamental concepts
in in that theory but you can have uh
different scientific theories with with
different fundamental concepts most of
modern science does take
space-time as fundamental but then
they'll also add other
other Concepts as well to be fundamental
like in evolution you'll also add
organisms and DNA and replication and
and so forth so but and so most
scientific theories also inherit the
assumption that reductionism is is a
good method most of them do um
I'll just I'll turn it over to John but
I'll just say that physicists now are
saying that space-time is not
fundamental like Neymar County himid and
and others and that therefore
reductionism
um is is doomed not just space-time but
reductionism is is doomed
um but but I'll stop there
so I agree with I think I'm agreeing
with Donald that
um I would want to distinguish uh
reductionism from claims of
fundamentality
um I think productionism is very
problematic
uh it has uh it gets you into certain
performative contradictions if you try
to make an absolute complete
reductionism because it gets you into
saying things like only the bottom level
is real and I know that from this level
up here which isn't real you get all
kinds of performative contradictions
going on there you have measurement
problems uh Wolfgang Smith has brought
this out you know the the ruler can't be
a Quantum thing to measure the Quantum
of things or you get into and I I won't
review that there's a host of problems
where I think reductionism and and a
completely flat ontology aren't uh
justifiable briefly why do you say
performative contradiction and not
contradiction performative contradiction
means that there isn't a contradiction
between propositions there's
contradictions between the activity and
the proposition stated here's one I'm
asleep right now
okay that doesn't make any sense it's a
performer contradiction because the
action
requires the the falsity of the
proposition right so can you explain why
suggesting that there's some ground
that's more real than a higher level is
a performative contradiction
ah what I was saying is if you if you
say that the bottom level is the only
level that's at re with real that is
clearly not the level at which the
science is being done the science is
being done by scientists using gauges
and writing things down and using
computers and using language and making
theories and going to conferences and if
all of that is not real because it's
somehow Epi phenomenal or illusory then
how is it that that level is giving you
epistemic access to the real bottom
level you're saying like it's be like
saying I'm in the middle of a dream and
in that dream I I dreamed that Santa
Claus was real therefore Santa Claus is
real like if if you if the level at
which you're doing the science is
illusory it undermines all the claims
you're making from that level you have
to be able to give it on top on
ontological reality to science if any of
its conclusions are going to be taken to
be real that's beautiful
thank you so that's I and there's a host
of other arguments and I I want to put
reductionism aside for that now
fundamental and I agree with Donald
completely fundamental is a theoretic
um but one thing you can be connoting
not denoting is what you think is the
the ontological referent uh which is
what some people sometimes mean by
fundamental and I I think instead of
using fundamental which is a theoretic
property we might want to use an
ontological property like real and then
you might be asking what is it to say
that something is real or to say that
one thing is more real than another and
I think that is an important question
and I think that question can't be
decided by just looking within any
particular theory for its particular
fundamentals because what we're asking I
think I would argue when we're asking
questions about reality is what what
what makes possible any and all such
intelligibility what makes possible any
possible theory that might turn out to
be true there has to be some aspect
because we take it I think that reality
in some sense corresponds to
our ability to make our claim to find
our claims true or our skills apply
applying or a perspectives present
um Etc so I I'm waving over with that
with my hand because that's a big thorny
knot but I'm trying to pull apart I
think there's reductionism which we put
aside there's fundamentality and I will
I agree with Donald what he just said
about that and but I think we have an
extra theoretic notion which is the
notion of realness which is something
like that which can make you know
various theories true how do they do it
and then the question might be are you a
pluralist or modest about that for
example that might be a starting point
do you think there are many different
realities that make theories true you
could be some kind of relativist in that
way or do you think that there is a
Ultimate Reality in some important
unified fashion Etc so there there's
three different questions we could be
asking reductionism which I I'd largely
put aside what's the fundamental of any
Theory but you might ask what's reality
and you might ask it in saying what is
it that could possibly integrate
non-reductively all these fundamentals
together so that we would have an over
our integrated coherent account
that's those those are the kinds of
moves you can make
did that make sense
sure so don
do you have anything to say in response
I think that
you know the notion of reality is an
extra notion Beyond just what's
fundamental to a particular Theory
that the and this whole area is very
very tricky you know for the very kinds
of performative contradiction reasons
that John just mentioned very very easy
to step on land mines everywhere here
but but it seems to me that that
girdle's in completeness theorem
tells us that in some sense there is no
Theory of Everything
right any formal system that is Rich
enough to model the
axiom's arithmetic is is either
inconsistent or incomplete and we call
it girdles in completeness theorem
because we don't take the inconsistency
thing too seriously so
that means no matter what
scientific theory we have
it's not the final word there'll always
be if the if the theory is Rich enough
to do arithmetic and most scientific
theories are they wouldn't be taken
seriously so they're rich enough to do
arithmetic so they're rich enough to
have a girdle statement that uh that is
outside their scope and yet it's true
um but not provable within that theory
and and no matter how much you add those
new statements to your your scientific
theory they'll always be new statements
that that so that that means that are
there there is no scientific theory of
everything
and the notion of Truth and and and I
think the related notion of reality
that's why I'm bringing this up the
notion of Truth and and the notion of
reality in some sense I think well
forever transcend
scientific theory and of course I'm a
scientist so I'm not saying oh throw up
our hands and yeah there's something
very deep going on here that that that
that
theories turn out to be empirically
quite valuable right we I'm alive today
because of scientific theories that that
led to medicine that has saved my life
so so the you know the stuff works even
though girl tells me that it that it's
um the theory is Trivial compared to the
truths that the theories uh can't prove
right so so there so the fact that you
can't have a theory of everything
um and you can't ultimately
know that the truth with a capital T and
therefore and this is where John may
want to disagree I don't know therefore
we can't know what what's reality with a
capital R we we can only say these are
the best theories we have so far but we
need to modestly and humbly say um
that's our Theory that's not the truth
and I would be fooled to say that that's
the reality
um so I would but I should probably stop
and let John react I just want to thank
Donald for being I hope I I follow his
example and continually make space for
him as well yeah okay great great so
apologies for me not making space here
for taking some space so with girdle's
incompleteness theorem you said that we
may never know truth with the capital T
and then you said that a tote may not
exist however there's the difference
between a toe existing and US knowing
the toe and when you said that we don't
know truth with a capital T to me that
truth with a capital t is the same as
the toe that's a statement then I'll get
you to respond to that and then second
is that there are certain assumptions in
girdle's theorem so for instance that
the laws would have to be based in first
order logic or that the laws are
consistent because consistency is
actually an implicit requirement and
it'd be strange to say that the world is
inconsistent though there are some
people who I'm sure on the more Mystic
end who may say that reality is a
contradiction paradoxes are at the
bottom and the top and there's no bottom
and top but there is
so those are some ways of getting around
it and that's why when I hear people
like myself maybe even two years ago
would say girdle's incompleteness
theorem says there is no toe uh that's a
bit dubious to me so I want to hear what
are your responses to that and then John
so please then comment
I like I'd like to hear Donald's
response to that first
right well so I I would say your point
is about taking Kurt the way I would
think about it is to say
the fact that we can't have a theory of
everything doesn't mean that there isn't
a truth out there
a real a real true reality
and from spiritual traditions we learned
that that perhaps um that's what you are
you're not divorced from that reality
you are that reality and and you can't
know that reality through intellectual
and conceptual knowing but you can know
it firsthand by being that reality and
so and so so there could be this notion
of truth and reality
uh that transcends the notion of a
theory of everything see a theory of
everything starts off with a finite set
of Concepts
and and and says here's how far I can go
with this set of Concepts
um and so my my argument would be you
know along the lines of girdle's kinds
of argument that if you start with any
finite axiomatization or any finite set
of Concepts you can come up with an
infinite number of theorems absolutely
you can come up with an infinite number
of theorems but there will be
probability zero compared to all the
truths that that that that that are out
there
um and so that's why I would I mean but
again there's this meta notion that John
was bringing up so I'm I'm here I am
talking about Truth uh using words
um and but but saying the concepts
themselves have very limited meaning the
the only
Escape out of it is for me is is this
issue that
um the spiritual Traditions bring up
which is um
you can't talk about the truth but you
are it your very being is it and and so
when you when you speak that being
itself is projecting down into a finite
set of Concepts to talk with with other
avatars of the being
um but and and so I think that there's a
way not to be self-refuting
um in that but I again I would love to
have John contradict me I don't know if
I'm going to contradict you or not
um
yeah I I I
think the go to argument still has value
with respect to formal systems
um whether or not theories are formal
systems I think it's a genuine
philosophical question
um I think uh you know we clearly had
theories before there was math
um and they're Bonafide theories Plato
has a theory of the psyche and whether
or not you could call that a formal
system
um I think is is questionable
um and and yet there was a lot of I
would say there's a lot of Truth in
Plato's uh Theory it turned out to be
you know it's been got quite a bit of
empirical confirmation uh recently so
um so I'm a little bit hesitant about
that but I take your point to be correct
uh Donald in fact I take it very deeply
and I actually think this is a platonic
point and this is something that comes
out in plania's work as well I take one
of the ways in which we determine that
something's real is precisely it it's
inexhaustibleness
um it's but it's not cacophonous and
exhaustibility and this is the thing
this is what I think Plato meant by the
good we get it's in it everything is an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
we can learn more and more so I do not
think there is a limited number of
truths about anything I think the number
of true even the number of true
descriptions of this very plain Stone
um is indefinitely large it's
inexhaustible
um Etc and this is what I talk about
multi-spectuality and things like that
so I don't think of
um I don't think I'm disagreeing with
you because I think that being an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
is precisely one of the ways in which we
determine that something is real uh and
um and I think that for phenomenological
reasons and for uh for cognitive reasons
I also think that truth is a
retrospective notion
um like real it's a comparative notion
um so when I say something's real or
something's an illusion I'm always
making a comparison when I say this is
true what I'm really saying
um is this is more true than that
because here's the limitations that that
have that I can see from here but I'm I
I I I right I'm a fallibalist that
doesn't mean that I then conclude oh
this Theory I can stop here because no
theory has ever done that and there's no
good reason to believe so right I'll
come to I'll have another transformative
moment where I'll say oh but that theory
turns out to be limited because of this
and to what do I point to that the
entire history of science the entire
history of science shows that to be the
case again and again and again and I
think that's the notion I think the
notion of Truth we're using is a
retrospective comparative notion
um I don't think that that means it's an
illusion I think we should give up the
Cartesian notion that truth points to
some complete absolute formalized grasp
of something and that the Criterion of
knowledge is certainty uh and because
we've tried that and it collapses it
certainly doesn't underwrite science uh
because you know it's it's very
plausibly the case that many of our
current best theories will turn out to
be rejected in the future right this is
Lawton's uh you know pessimistic
argument I think it has to be taken very
seriously now the last thing that Donald
said and what I think with him is
convergent with everything I just said
send Shivers up my spine because you
know I've been I've been arguing that
there are kinds of knowing other than
propositional inferential there's
procedural there's perspectival and
there's participatory which is knowing
by being and I agree that many of these
mystical Traditions say you know the the
way to come in most contact with reality
is not through your conceptual
propositional knowing but it's through
your perspectival and all ultimately
your participatory knowing and I agree
that that that
is always the case no no give me a
moment here what I mean by that is
something like what Marlo Ponte or or 40
Cox I would say right is
even my propositional things are
ultimately dependent on skills my skills
are dependent on perspectives my
perspectives are always dependent on
participatory identity and so the
spiritual Traditions are not they're
just explicating something that is
always the case they're not proposing
something that's over there that only
only the great gifted ones can realize
um I mean that's part of I think what a
little bit wrong with the way some of
these spiritual Traditions have been
taken up right but I think what the
spiritual Traditions are pointing to is
exactly that fact that that there's a
there's an asymmetric dependence
relation the proposition is dependent on
the procedural the procedural is
dependent on the perspectival and the
perspectival is dependent on the
participatory and so for me I try to
understand realness in terms of what
best integrates those four together
um when we're making claims of about how
things are
well very good very very good you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy